hello winter welcomed video playing LM
llm okay um yeah what to do here
something else I want to play the Pogo
all the time but they have not yet made
up my mind what I do instead Queens
gambit ism is solid but also not very
exciting okay here there's night b5 i
think is a threat is it a threat mm-hmm
I don't think so maybe I'm wrong okay
doesn't seem to be a threat I thought
take stakes not be five sometimes an
option but probably I was correct in
assuming it's nothing special
the here black should be okay the only
route see one in this structure is not
considered to be particularly dangerous
there are various versions of that
positioned with age three played a three
blade and look see one is some one of
the lesser um threatening versions the a
queen a fire has something that is a bit
bothersome for white yeah the good news
for black in this position is some he
has good chances to equalize the bad
newses to win a game the right player
basically has to fall asleep roop the
eighth and t4 is that is the key idea
here you can normally take and play
deform d4 immediately it might also be
also interesting well yes not castle
that some okay put here okay probably
gets get things back maybe rookie aight
here i can take be to rupee one down
okay let's go here t will probably go
back to be three
No
okay Oh Wade rookie seven no there's no
background guess you briefly thinking
some background problem but doesn't seem
to be okay 95 for a pen that can be a
sailfin in some cases it's not back he
wants to go queen age seven here right
that is the idea I came to like maybe I
could have taken between what the Queen
takes a seven the the back rank
okay um t7 here I cannot take yet should
be four maybe now I can take these seven
right Stan a problem with this don't see
any lab you should back to see six and
then I'm very safe with two minor pieces
against them against the rook
and no background may please and now
rupee eight night and for this kind of
thing try and form a meeting attack
that's the best way to try end games
might might prove to be um yeah my proof
to be tricky it's more interesting to
try to attack here with the night and
bishop combination
identify and so on ok yeah here I will
take put the weakened pawn structure i'm
okay with the trade mmm i need to
activate the rook the good thing is that
this Bishop is keeping everything so
nicely protected check
you
Jack White resigns yeah those are
surprisingly straightforward wind out of
this quite lame opening yeah sometimes
White has issues with the slide um lack
and development but it should never be a
real issue but i don't know maybe queen
queen bee three years it's looking very
normal this move but i don't think it's
particularly helpful let's say as he is
in those in those potential forks all
the time yeah you want to play this for
example but night f form it's also
problem and here this is all so bad that
it probably has to do this I mean black
is equalizing but this is just the
nature of that line and deform chicser
now I just took it cream take so the
engine wants to play FDX knowing though
yeah and showing no prejudices yet maybe
this is really bad it covers those
squares and the f file is open this
seems to be better what the engine is
recommending here funny movie now check
yeah but why this white is not losing
here check it's nice for black but it's
not a loss as some funny possibilities
yeah I didn't didn't see that coming but
it's probably not bad now this have no
ever seems to be a mistake okay everyone
is given by the computer it's about
equal he I can also take be tool that
would have been stronger can't just just
take him
I was I was a little bit concerned about
Queen 87 this was the thing but the
computer just wants to play with 88 and
says I'm winning really wonder why am i
burning him let's say in for just just
to show in a 94 okay I gotta text here
here and it will possibly okay hmm
tricky antioch cd1 was still ok now why
this struggling Queenie 30 ever as a bit
a bit more this is the thing but watch
in Asia's Queen III now I can take yeah
it's a pause I guess oops yeah this is a
winning position I think black and also
easily coordinate him now just gain
space and at the later King g7 night f4
would be a very strong attack that's g4
possibly and the pieces here so nicely
coordinated especially the anchor bishop
on c6 is very helpful that's something
that very often is underestimated how
important it is to have anchors for your
pieces the bishop on c6 for example is
protecting b7 and it's it forms a unit
here the whole Queen side is a very
harmonious unit and the bishop is
fantastically placed them yeah he went
here and now i'm happy to trade because
now his pawns IAM a week without the
weak points to the two pieces against
the rook is not an easy technical task
but here is rather the easiest you will
win the pawns probably quite quite
easily okay thanks for watching